hey guys welcome back to the evan and
caitlin podcast where today we're going
to be answering all of those diy
questions that you've been diying to ask
[Music]
like dying to ask dying
yeah the conviction behind that really
convinced me thanks
well you know i we feel like for two
people with a diy channel we don't
really talk about diying
very much on this podcast and we do get
questions about it so yeah
but but today we we're answering um all
your diy questions we put out
um a poll uh or a
call for questions call for questions on
our subreddit on twitter and on our
youtube community and we're going to be
going through all of those but first
what's new caitlyn oh you wrote down
things for what's new oh yeah i'm sorry
i don't have anything new my my life's
the same
because i went to a physical therapist
for my arm shoulder wrist things
and um so i'm going to start going to
more regular physical therapy to like
get all that back on track but yeah a
lot of it is due to a swimming injury
from like
high school yeah still haunting me which
i think we kind of suspected that like
the shoulder
was that because you had injured your
shoulder but we didn't know that the
other stuff was related yeah it's like
the nerve gets pinched up here and that
that gets my whole
arm and sometimes my leg too which is
crazy um
but honestly like that sent me down like
this huge
like side quest rabbit hole of like
split mechanical keyboards because i'm
supposed to keep my like
well you were already down that side
quest when you already had this
in general no that you already had the
split mechanical keyboard before your
physical therapy and the vertical mouse
that was your thing of the week last
time
oh yeah it's all my ergonomic journey
it's but
the the this sent you down a further
rabbit hole to even
weirder split mechanical keyboard so
weird like
like where where the layout is like
straight up and down columnar and stuff
and like
well there's one that you're looking at
where it's like it's a split keyboard
and you have your hands resting on each
one and they are
like the mouse and so you're just you
have like keyboard mittens on and you
just
like a dj and that moves your mouse and
you type at the same
time it's crazy it's crazy now all of
these are like very expensive and
custom-made and stuff which is why i
like
it i spent such a long time researching
it because i don't want to make a
mistake and stuff but i finally ordered
one it'll get in like
five weeks yeah because i'm impatient at
least you have your other split keyboard
yeah but i i think i'm becoming like a
split keyboard advocate now like
at least for people with shoulder
problems but like
eventually everyone's gonna have
shoulder problems right we're all gonna
be old one day
and like you know like if in our
generation i'm sure that like we're
gonna be old
like sitting there playing like
minecraft like
oh can you build that cat statue
faster
it's definitely gonna be just trying to
come up with a realistic situation here
honey can you pass me some baked
potatoes
i'm low on health i thought you started
that farm
i was done i'm making it an auto farm
why are we so low on potatoes all the
time you're responsible for the food
oh that's great i'm looking forward to
that
um yeah but that's that's that's where i
uh
that's where i've sunk a little bit of
time recently it's been a nice rabbit
hole to fall into
i just hope that the you know it
continues to improve
your shoulder and all that stuff it has
been improving
so thank you for for listening to my
story
anyways on me are you thanking them
thanking them
thank you for putting up with me like
looking into keyboards while you edit
it's important it's important okay so on
to the main topic of the day why you
maybe
clicked on this podcast um let's just
jump straight into
the questions first off we got a lot of
questions about
tool recommendations and everything like
that that seems to be like
one of the like most common questions
that we get asked
every time we do a q a and we um didn't
want to
get too specific for any one person's
very specific scenario just because we
want this to be like
everyone to be able to listen to it but
there are some um things that
i think individuals ask that could be
helpful for lots of people
yeah yeah so missy from twitter asks
what tool do you regret purchasing the
most and related to that
column the destroyer asks what would you
say was the best investment tool-wise
and there's lots of similar questions
along those lines yeah that's right
regret and best tool investment
um
i think there's kind of like a category
of regret where we
um buy something because we're
kind of testing it out and it ends up
being
not that great because we got like a
cheaper option and then
we just don't use it because it's not
great
and we don't necessarily have the room
for the better option
or well i guess sometimes we end up
getting the better option then we throw
the old one
yeah or not throw it away but we like
give it to goodwill or something
i think that you know this is a tough
question to start out i don't know why i
put this first
um but i think that like if i venture
into
all of the tools we use including camera
gear
and everything like that yeah i could
have some great answers
we did get some questions that were more
related to the filming
side of like filming diy projects and
we're
we are not including those in this today
because we wanted this to be more about
diy so we're not going to get into like
camera equipment
what do i think was the best thing we
bought and the worst
okay does resin count as a tool
no
[Laughter]
um yeah well we didn't really think
about this too
i wanted it to be real i wanted like the
discussion to happen right now
um is it lame to say like this one
screwdriver that i really like
i mean honestly i use that screwdriver
all the time
and it's like my super screwdriver i
know one of mine what's that
so in terms of best yeah when we
got our miter saw yeah we
originally did kind of have just like a
small basic one
and we liked what a miter saw did
so much um and if you're not super
familiar with diy that's the one that
it's like it's kind of on a stand
and there's a big spinning wheel and we
lower the wheel you said if you're not
familiar with diy you said
you said miter saw yeah yeah if you're
not like a
if you're like new to diy you might not
know
like i'm not gonna assume everyone like
knows what every single type of saw is
oh no yeah yeah so
that's the one where you've seen us use
there's a big vertical spinning wheel
and we lower it down to the wood and
raise it back up and the reason we like
it is because it's like very controlled
you know like you're not free wielding a
blade you know and stuff like that
um yeah and when we bought our new one
we did
it was a splurge for us especially at
the time where we got one that could do
different angles and like
had a really deep cutting area and it
was like nice and we got like
like a folding stand that we could roll
and stuff yeah and i do not regret that
investment of the whole the whole thing
the whole package i think that if you
are gonna get started into diy
you know we get a lot of questions about
this we generally say um
you know start with what will motivate
you to finish the project come up with
like an objective before you start
buying tools come up with the project
come up with the projects yeah but i
think that in terms of the best bang for
your buck
i mean a miter saw and the kreg jig like
a pocket hole jig of some sort oh yeah
you can do a lot with that you can do so
much with just those two things
but do you have regret ones i don't
really have regret once like
i'm trying to think of i feel like
there's been some things like didn't we
like
buy one vacuum chamber type and then we
had to get another vacuum chamber
because like it wasn't
or maybe it wasn't vacuum chamber like
nothing really springs to mind in terms
of like oh i regret that oh the
sledgehammer
okay the sledgehammer was a little bit
of an impulse
just because like i was like
sledgehammer
this is before we we just moved into the
house and evan was like we
obviously need a sledgehammer because
you know we're totally one day gonna
bust up that patio in the backyard and
replace the patio with a new one
like we're gonna do that ourselves no we
hit the corner you hit the corner of the
patio once for an inaugural whack
and we know we've never used that
sledgehammer and it's big and it's heavy
and it takes up a lot of space
well i think that also i i'm kind of
just scrolling back through some of our
videos and everything like that to see
if anything like
strikes me i was like we should have
just done this from the beginning
or something like that i think that
because
for most of our diy career we have had
like in our mind that this is gonna be
like a business and this is long term
and i think that just from our past life
experiences we knew that like getting
the cheaper
somewhat like slightly you know maybe
more compromised
for money you know purchase might haunt
us later on so in general i think we
have
leaned towards like getting the more
like
maybe once we like knew
that um but like you know remember when
i bought that really big expensive vice
and you're like do we need a vice this
big
oh yeah and how much that box that's a
great well that's a great example of one
that
an investment you don't regret super
expensive very heavy duty vice
yeah it's great but i think with a lot
of things we did that but didn't you get
like a base for that vise that was also
super heavy and expensive that we never
used
oh that was for no yes yes
i did get an adjustable vice that is one
that i regret
but the reason why i got that is for um
our our drill press i thought i could
like really precisely position things
under it
using that vice but the drill press we
bought is from
um harbor freight it's really cheap
it doesn't hold it it's not adjustable
it's um
that's one of those tools that when we
have a bigger workshop we will be
replacing
quickly and i think that like you know
we bought you know for the drill press
there are some things where we did
compromise just because
we you know we didn't have space for
that or we don't have like a use for it
all the time
yeah like the drill press are like our
band saw is kind of janky we have some
like sanders that are kind of janky
yeah you know we have a lot of things
that like that are like half jank
we kind of got the cheaper version
because we weren't ready for the
real big legit version oh we didn't have
room mainly because of size
yeah mainly because of size yeah yeah
but i think that yeah in terms of
what tool do you regret purchasing the
most often times when we com
uh compromise um and we have to buy
something else
and what would you say was the best
investment tool wise
are you just answering the questions
again we've already answered that one i
know i was just trying to like summarize
it
it really depends on what type of thing
we're talking about
i'm just gonna cheat here and say our
microphones okay
that doesn't count we already gave real
answers miter saw the vice
yeah like you know yeah
but it it's gonna differ i think one
reason that those popping in my head
is they're very they're tools that get a
lot of use for a lot of different type
of projects
yeah you know some things are so
specific
and they might be really cool but like
how often do we use them you know yeah
so i think that's good all right let's
jump categories to
resin and uh poopy head
from reddit asks what do you what made
you want to do your first resin project
i wanted to make a geode table yeah i
mean again
we were kind of following our own advice
we had an
idea for the project we had a vision
that we wanted to accomplish accomplish
and we knew that resin
was the right thing to do that with and
that's what you know got us
over the learning hump and over the
motivation hump
uh we'll talk about motivation later in
this because we've got some questions
perhaps but
um well i think it's really hard to um
well i was going to go into motivation
but go for it
like it's it's really hard to motivate
yourself when you
don't know why you're trying to motivate
yourself
which is why and it's really hard to
build a workshop when you don't know
what you're building a workshop
for which is why like our answer to
those to motivation questions and to
like what kind of tools do i get how do
i get started questions
almost always go back to like well what
do you want to make yeah
you know because that's your motivation
is like to to
make a thing like you're you should be
excited about something specifically
and i think that i i relate to the the
source of those questions too because
when i was younger and i like you know
was
dreaming of the future i just kind of
dreamed of a workshop
filled with tools that i'll do things
with
you know and like the the like goal in
my head
was to be able to make whatever i wanted
but when i was younger i didn't really
have
any visions for those objects
interesting
i think maybe i'm just a more like
results different driven
i don't know like maybe i no no but like
i i'm agreeing with where we are now you
know i think you should always start
with what you want
um so maybe maybe one one way to go
about it is instead of
like trying to like research what tools
to get
research what projects a site excite you
go to instructables
go to reddit go to you know whatever
yeah whatever source of inspiration that
you might find
find that inspiration first and then
start researching what tools will allow
you to accomplish that goal
yeah so find that inspiration first yeah
i think that's pretty good advice that's
a good idea
good job of having yourself in the back
you're going to pull a shoulder
[Music]
okay so let's go back to tools um
what are tools you think that everyone
should have in their home i do have some
recommendations for this
a really good multifunctional
screwdriver that has all the bits stored
in the handle
i really like that one i have a um
one it'll be in the it'll be in the car
it'll be in the description
um i think a drill yeah
it makes things so much easier a hammer
gotta hang your pictures
are you looking up our recommended tool
list i'm looking at my recommended tool
list
what else what else comes to your mind
uh
measuring tape oh measuring tape oh
measuring tape for sure
um i mean
some things i'm trying to think of like
the the
stuff you do as a
homeowner stud finder
maybe i just feel like that's so
specific you might not you might not
need it
um but i think a drill a hammer
you like a handful of utility knives
like your utility knife um
but again i wouldn't suggest necessarily
just getting them just getting them
because
you know most of the time you're
probably not gonna have a like picture
hanging emergency
you know i guess if you want to think of
like oh what things might you need to
have on hand in an emergency
maybe like would you need like a pipe
wrench or something if you need to like
oh you're like the only emergencies i
can really think of are going to be like
plumbing
yeah maybe maybe like some adjustable
crescent wrenches
and some if you need to like tighten the
pipe and
yeah and then like a pipe wrench yeah
two pipe wrenches two
two pipe wrenches you need two tons and
maybe two
crescent wrenches yeah but other than
that you just buy stuff as you need it
and i think a measuring tape i think a
measuring tape i think everyone should
have a measuring tape if you like
a pretty small investment or in like a
house or apartment just because like
you're like
well if i'm going to buy a couch how big
is it or if i'm going to like you know
it's good for visualizing yeah but
beyond that i'm not sure
like a ruler
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
a flashlight a tool i know a headlamp oh
a headlamp that seems more like a tool
that's important i don't know why
they're both lights
go get duct tape is that a tool or is
that a material
always have duct tape always always have
blue painters tape your blue painters
green yeah whichever or whichever
whichever
tape you want safety glasses safety
glasses
safety glasses you only get two eyes and
then they don't get your eyes and like
like if you're drilling into drywall or
doing anything like in the attic
you need safety yeah safety oh gloves
yeah okay gloves gloves uh hearing
protection i don't think most people
need to
feel like that's not as like of a basic
need
well this is like kind of ironic to say
right now but like masks
for a lot of things like if you going
into the attic or you're drilling above
you
or like drywall yeah yeah masks
yeah i think that's about it yeah i
think we can move on from this question
because we're at a point where we're
just like literally scrolling through
our own website right now
ah yeah that's true but i think there's
some good basics all right
back to no i'm going to skip over res
and i'm going to go to planning
logistics
this is this is a good oh i like this
one yeah i like this question
so oreos pasta from the youtube
community page
asks where is the line between diy and
just call a pro for you
and related to that melanie messner from
twitter asks
when you just need something for your
house or something breaks how do you
decide when to diy or when to just go
buy it
so i will say our answer is different
now than it was before the channel
yes because our answer now is
will it make a good video if it will
make a good video
then we will do it ourselves yeah if it
will not make a good video
then we will typically either hire a pro
or higher the thing like solve it with
by paying for it yeah i mean but that's
that's
solely because we're so tight on time
yeah
so i think like the more applicable
answer yeah
before before we were yeah the more
applicable answer for everyone is kind
of how we did things before we were
content creators
and i think um
so it's it's kind of different like call
a pro versus just buy it
the just buy a thing is assuming like
you can make a thing or buy a thing when
i think of call of pro i think of like
you're either fixing something yourself
or calling someone to fix it
so they're sort of separate for the call
of pro it's partially
uh how badly can you mess it up so
electrical yeah so like electrical yeah
um how
complicated is it like how easy is it to
research
or do yourself you know something like
paint like you can't mess it up that
badly you can't mess it up you know what
i mean
like if you don't like it you just buy
more paint but something like electrical
you could really mess that up
um or even something like plumbing you
could really mess that up ironically we
did do some plumbing ourselves yeah
um and then also like how much money are
you going to save by doing it yourself
because a lot of these things
like okay gutters for example if you get
a line of gutter replaced
it's not gonna i don't think it you will
save much money doing it yourself
because
like the professionals that do it have
like this long line of gutter they can
cut it at the perfect length and you
have to buy like
segments you know like and it's not as
good of an end product yeah
and gutters is a great example of like
hire it out you know
you can't um yeah so it's like how
how bad will it be if you mess it up how
much money do you save and also like
can you get like a similarly good
product
and the gutters is another great example
because if you do your gutters yourself
you're going to have like these joints
you won't have a continual run of gutter
and honestly like we've had this happen
to us this
wasn't the gutter that we installed
ourselves but like when your gutter
fails
and it gets clogged up or if it wasn't
angled right and everything
it can get so heavy it just tears your
whole side of your house out not the
whole side but it's the
fascia yeah well yeah like it just tore
a chunk of like our our
roof off yeah we just woke up in the
morning we're getting ready to go to
work in the morning and your gutter's
off yeah and we called into work we're
like okay we're gonna fix our house
instead sorry
yeah like it was it was open to the like
our attic was open to the air
and the weather and the rain and stuff
but like for example um
another thing that we hired out was our
floors
we have like laminate wood flooring in
our house and
we actually tried to do considered we
tried to do our
our laundry room yeah we tried to do our
laundry room um well uh
we considered doing the wood floors
ourselves
um we ended up hiring someone just
because it was like such a
big project like it's not something we
could just dip our toes into and i'm so
glad we did because
there's like so many complications that
came up with our floor
like our sub floor being unlevel and we
tried
we were like oh well we'll hire out the
wood floors but we'll do tile in our
laundry room and we tried to level it
oh my god we should have that should
have been a sign that we would be cursed
by leveling things forever
we tried to level that floor and it was
so messed up we had to call someone to
come fix our mistakes
yeah and and that's one where you you
can mess up you know
but like you know at the same time you
know removing your old floor
like you know carpet or something like
that oh yeah you could like probably
remove
you could probably remove carpet or
something like that and if it looks if
the floor is great underneath it
maybe you can just do it yourself you
know so so
one big recommendation that i have for
both of these questions
is look up a youtube video first oh yeah
and if while you're watching it you're
like
oh okay okay you know like i said
electrical
electrical is something that you might
want to hire out especially like running
a new run or
adding a new box or something like that
those are things that you might
like if you want to swap a light fixture
yeah so it's like if
if you look up a youtube video and
they're like okay go out to your uh
breaker box turn the house power off
just
unscrew here screw this back and boom
you're done yeah you can do that we're
replacing an outlet
you know like if you look up a youtube
video and you're like oh yeah i
understand that
i have a complete understanding of this
and i i'm good to go
then maybe go for it but like if if
if uh like with some plumbing things too
so many plumbing things it could be like
a whole bunch of different issues
so you might want to call a plumber who
has more experience
who can like just through years of
experience can troubleshoot it a lot
faster than you can and you might mess
it up so
yeah i think um watch watch some youtube
videos if you can find the answer and it
looks doable
maybe do it yourself but if you can't
find the answer or you're like
no and if there's minimal risk of like
messing things up super badly
also be realistic with yourself about
how much time you have and how much time
the project will take
yes do you want that hole in your
ceiling to be there forever no that's
why we hired someone to fix the hole in
our ceiling when evan fell through it or
we knew we didn't have time to patch it
ourselves yeah even though we've patched
ceilings before you know and also
anytime you're estimating how long a
project will take
multiply it by two and then by two again
and then by two again yeah yeah it's
gonna take longer
remember when i bought all those
electrical outlets and i was gonna
replace them all around the house
yeah when we first bought the house and
we still have a bucket of them yeah yeah
i got half of them yeah you got half of
them the other half we just put
furniture in front of them
it's fine that's fine
okay let's move to another resin one um
uh gunno girl from twitter says if
if i've never done resin but i find it
amazing and magical what would you
recommend i start off with
on a budget i probably have zero tools
that
we do and i think an apartment dweller
with i'm an apartment dweller with no
experience
so there's a couple parts to this
question one i will say
is resin is not cheap um
now i have like i have heard rumors that
michael's started selling
resin and maybe it's a little bit
cheaper there i don't know but i've
seen
yeah so um resin is not
a cheap thing now it is messy and it's
messy
it's fumey um cleanup
can be bad you know you
will probably go through a bunch of like
stir sticks and tiny measuring cups and
stuff
yeah um you probably need to put like
tarps everywhere
yeah or get like a silicone mat but i
think if you do want to get started i
think actually
you know we started doing like big
geode slices oh no we started with
little coasters
so i think the best way to get started
is um
buy small pre-existing molds like don't
worry about making your own molds yet
because that's a whole nother thing
um and honestly i would say uv resin is
probably less intimidating
i think uv resin is a little bit less
intimidating
because you don't have to mix it and you
can make really small things really i
wonder with uv resin i guess you could
just open up the doors to your house or
something or whatever
i mean you can get a uv light and it's
not that
yeah i mean because you can't do uv
resin experiments outside because it'll
just start curing right away
no but you can i mean you can open up
your doors and
turn on a fan yeah yeah you know like
also
it also depends on how much resin you're
using if you're just making like tiny
little charms
yeah i mean we're not the we're not the
resin
safety police experts read the
directions on whatever resident you get
things differ yada yada you know
depending on the formula and everything
i think because like
uv resin you can buy such a small
container of it because i think part of
it is like i don't want to get these
like a two
two gallon jugs of resin for my first
time because
what if i try it i'm not good what if i
don't like it it can you know yellow
over time in the bottles and stuff
you know and um so that's another reason
why i think like if you just want to
kind of dip your toes
um just find the smallest container you
can buy
maybe that's two part resin maybe it's
uv resin they both have their benefits
okay so that's that's the resin part
what would you recommend for colorants
uh mica powder and alcohol ink yeah
if you're gonna choose only one probably
mica powder probably micropowder yeah
that's what we use the most it's more
it's more resiny it like does anything
it's what gives it the swirly pearly
look
alcohol ink um you can do some really
cool effects with it and it can also
give it like a translucent color but
yeah
personally the one that we use the most
is um mica powder and when you think of
like
resiny stuff you're probably picking
especially on the furniture side now
some people do like the alcohol drops on
top and they do the blooms down and
there's all of that yeah so see what
inspiration
you find inspiration yeah find find your
inspiration
figure out how to do that technique and
buy what you need for that yeah but yeah
we like
uh we probably use mica powders the most
yeah yeah yeah
okay so going back to tool
recommendations there's just so many
um what's your most fun tool to use
um oh this is from um our craft from
reddit what's your most fun tool to use
like i look forward to using the bandsaw
whenever i can because i enjoy it the
most
i like power carving oh yeah
power carving is fun um
it's just so fast it's so fast it's very
satisfying usually you're doing
something
that doesn't have to be the most precise
it's a little bit more artistic
um so i think power carving is fine even
like
uh like when we did our wooden resin
computer we did some power carving but
we also did some like
dremel carving and i think that was
really fun like carving is just fun
it's kind of more artistic um
i like that um there's a lot of tools
that i i like enjoy using because
they're
precise and feel sturdy and safe and i
like that um but in terms of fun i feel
like it's got to be power carving
what about it
no that was a little bit of a joke
answer in terms of what
like like for me it's like i love tools
and everything in general
and i think that it's hard for me to
choose a single tool i just like being
able to
make what's in my head come out
in a physical form yes also this podcast
has been blessed the supervisor is in my
lap the supervisor has arrived
um honestly like when i think back this
is kind of a weird or lame answer it
might be un
unexpected for a lot of people but like
if i could only use like one tool in a
strange way it might be a 3d printer
i know we haven't done many 3d printer
projects i know that we
it is one of the most fun for you to use
though i do really like 3d modeling and
then 3d printing stuff
it's just yeah you can just do so much i
can just do so much
so i i think it's like a surprise answer
for me too
um because it's not really like actively
fun to use
but like just my mind loves it like the
idea of a 3d printer
because like i see things in 3d i can
like make them
because i have 3d modeling experience
and then boom they come out
and yeah it's good it's cool um
there's another nerdy question for nerdy
answer that i can provide
mr can't play guitar from reddit asks
what are your favorite phone apps for
makers or for diy stuff
yeah do you have an answer i have an
answer what's your answer mcmaster car
they make an app oh they have an app
they have an app
and you can just like look up like all
sorts of like
tools and supplies and everything like
that like
for example on the tensegrity table so
many people asked like
where did you buy that tensioning rig to
tension all the cables
no no i just browsed mcmaster card until
i found all the components that i wanted
and you built them put it together and i
built it with little
angle brackets and and everything typing
in and
sorting everything to be exactly what i
wanted
yes yeah that's a good answer so i mean
i i've definitely
at some times in my past just spent some
time just browsing
tools and supplies mm-hmm just because i
like that
i also this is kind of lame and it's not
really an app but just some
sort of place to document your research
for a specific project
like we on every um every for every
single one of our projects we make a
shared google doc
and we have you know some of the youtube
stuff down below like where we can write
down title and tags and
description and stuff but then above we
have an area for
planning and notes and you know we can
link to youtube videos that we've
you know researched we can link to
different tools and i just think it's a
helpful way to gather
diy and making is youtube
nice evan's evan's wing there's just one
channel i really like
called everything actually there's five
channels i really like how many channels
do we have now
yeah but they're not all diy that's true
yeah evan's winking a lot
juby you have some ear itches
oh and now you're giving me kisses thank
you well related to that we have two
questions both from reddit well i guess
that's taken
and have canoe will travel asked
how would you all recommend planning out
long-term diy projects what sort of
tools
whether they're physical or digital
would be best for organizing during the
whole thing
and then when considering a new type of
project how much research you do before
committing to it
watch a ton of youtube videos and read a
ton of articles or just
jump in and try it hold on i have a
question
real quick we're recording on the
camcorder we're not recording on obs
we can we can add it in later right
we're getting audio
surprise face i just noticed because i
was like
checking our live time are we okay
is recording right i can just green
screen us in you're gonna screen screen
that's in oh man that's embarrassing
no it's okay this is how that's how we
used to do it well yeah but
thank goodness we have the backup i know
oh wow
i guess you didn't start push recording
at the beginning i thought you i thought
i did i i remember
i remember pushing the button pushing
and waiting yeah and i didn't see an
error message
i know anyways we'll get back to the
questions but
we'll i'll edit it no one's gonna know
the difference it's fine
so it honestly really depends on the
type of project
sometimes for the experience of
like us in a way we kind of want to go
in blind for example candle making
we did just enough research to find the
kits but we didn't do
like all of the research on like all the
ways it can fail
and all that because we didn't we wanted
to experience that genuinely
in the moment yeah um now would we
recommend that if you're not a content
creator trying to make an entertaining
video
i would recommend doing more research
yeah yeah
um and i think youtube is honestly one
of the best places
yeah we do for for a lot of things where
we like
want it to turn out correctly and
everything
so for most of our videos we do a decent
amount of research
we watch youtube videos we read articles
um
and all of that stuff and then we
organize them all into a google doc
um with like and then and then also
sometimes
we then will three model it or caitlyn
will make a mock-up of it
or we'll do both and then we'll even
sometimes write steps
1 through 12 for us to follow
because while we're filming we're
juggling so much
and we don't want to like forget mold
release
yeah sometimes we do even even if we do
write it down we forget
things um but again i guess most people
won't be filming it so it's a little bit
easier
to like pause but i do think um
like having one big master doc or
something to gather all of your
resources but then
jotting down like the actual steps just
so you don't have to read through so
much when you're out in the workshop
yeah um it's like when we were doing the
resin keycaps
we like did a little diagram for
ourselves and we're like okay the first
coat needs to be clear yeah and then
we're going to do our embeds then we're
going to do space background one and
then space back on darker and then clear
again or whatever
um so in terms of planning i'd recommend
a physical document
or a digital document to organize it all
gather your links
write out the steps and stuff but then
also it's really nice having just a
normal notebook
so when you are like you know grab your
calipers and you like
measure something in the shop or like
you know draw out a diagram or something
like that it's
those two in combination because we
sketch a decent amount
just like on paper um it's like we'll
either use you know 3d modeling or
photoshop or something to do
more final designs but when we're just
kind of brainstorming
we'll sketch a lot yeah
okay so um back to tools
there's there's a lot of questions from
that um
a dds asks what are some things that you
would want to do for your next house
that you can't do with your current
tools
what are those tools and how much do you
invest in them yeah
so i think it's hard to say like what
projects we'll want to do in
a new house but there are tools that we
want to have in our new house that we
definitely don't have room for
yeah i think one of the first that i'm
really excited to get
is an actual legit big table saw
yes yes because we have a little
contractor grade one and it makes us
nervous every single time we use it
because table saws are
scary and we want a big sturdy one
yeah throwback to like another question
that was asked carolina on twitter asks
is there a power tool that's way too
scary for you to ever
get used like we got it we use it
because we use it when we have to
but like okay so here's a little like
behind the scenes thing
a lot of times when we build furniture
and stuff um
so just to give like a little a little
bit of like
background if you're not super familiar
with like there's all these different
types of saws and what do you use them
for
um uh table saws are usually used for
like ripping wood which means like
picture you have like
a one by like a one by 12
and you need to make it a little bit
skinnier than it is
long ways that's how you slice off like
a thin
part of it whereas like a miter saw is
for cross cuts
so if you want to make it a little bit
shorter instead of a little bit skinnier
so a lot of times when we are building
furniture and stuff
we will design the piece of furniture so
that we can use all
dimensional lumber and we don't have to
do any
like ripping on the table saw we don't
need to make any of the boards skinnier
and that's just how we design our stuff
so that we can avoid the table saw
completely now sometimes it's right i
think that's
that's a smart that's a smart way to do
things honestly
yeah it's like you can you can do stuff
like that so if you're in a
apartment and all you have room for is
like a circular saw or something and you
don't want to do long cuts just design
stuff that doesn't need any long cuts
yeah like you can do a lot with that we
we've probably used our table saw like
two times in 2020 you know like we don't
use it very often
and honestly honestly sometimes when we
do use it
we don't even like film it just because
like
you know caitlyn has to be on one end
and i need to be on the other at times
and we want to
you know and we don't actually like
because it is a slightly more dangerous
tool
um we don't want to like ever think
about any filming
sides of it we want and if we do all of
our minds to be about
like safety and all of that stuff and
when you get a bigger table saw it's um
it's it's you still have to worry about
it but it's
much more solid there's more tables on
all sides
well and then there's even things like
the saw stop where like it will retract
you know if it senses human flesh you
know so
um but we just don't really have the
the space like that space for what we
want
but also like we were saying earlier
like you know i want like a
more legit sander like a bigger belt
sander a bigger
bigger drill press yeah drill press we
want a laser cutter
yeah we want to um set up the lathe
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah we haven't talked
about that yes one of our one of our
patrons was
kind enough to send us a whole lathe but
we don't really have room in the shop
um we've considered a bigger cnc yeah
bigger cnc
it depends on how big this hop we get is
yeah a lot of it depends
yeah but we we definitely need more room
but i think the more common theme
like the most common theme is just the
more legit versions
of the tools that we have and oftentimes
the more
quote unquote legit ones just take up
more physical space
yeah yeah i mean it makes sense
because like oftentimes more features
takes more space
too you know now this i thought was an
interesting question from
josh zesner on youtube alton brown has a
philosophy about not buying single-use
kitchen utensils
do you have an example of this in the
diy workshop have you purchased anything
that was single use and was it useful or
not
and i find it interesting because like
when it comes to kitchen utensils
like i have a very strong aversion to
single-use stuff unless it's something
that like
i know we're gonna use a lot like we
like our
our mandolin slicer is kind of single
use but we use that thing all the
freaking time some french fries
yeah how else we gonna slice our fries
and sometimes other stuff we'll see
french fries and zucchini we eat that a
lot
yeah um but
i feel like with our workshop especially
now that it is our jobs i think we're
much more open
to buying single use stuff
but it's still like we're still limited
on space so we're
probably less likely to buy a single use
thing if it takes up a ton of space yeah
but if it's
smaller we're more like cool with it
well so it's like
sometimes we have no choice like i'm
just kind of looking through like i'm
just like looking around
the room we're in right now and i see
the tile clock that we
we had that we made where we covered it
in alcohol
ink and resin and in order to drill a
hole through it
we needed a very specific ceramic drill
bit
we bought a set of them and we used one
once
and it's still in our cabinet
yep you know and like there's no way to
get around that and it's like
it's it's it's we had to do it
um so we can't control that and because
it's small enough not to be a huge
inconvenience we're keeping them because
we might use it eventually in the future
who knows
but something like the um like craig jig
stuff because we do pocket holes in a
lot of different projects
even though it's kind of a one
like a single use thing it's different
if it's if you use that use a bunch
or like oh this is another great great
example um
for the uh for the
catwheel we we bought and we used a
router adapter for cutting circles
and it worked great and now it's the
only way to cut it for us because our
cnc wasn't big enough
and so we had to do it and it's still
hanging around on our
shop wall yeah because it's not like
it was expensive enough not to like give
away afterwards and we might use it in
the future
yeah um but i think you just have to
like
you know for for some types of projects
and tasks there are
you know many ways to skin a potato
um but uh for certain things
there is going to be one way that's so
far superior so it's like do you want to
do that project enough
to be worth the cost and the space taken
up by the thing and you just have to ask
yourself that
i have an example and a philosophy to
put forth ooh yes drop it on us baby
for me i love multi-use
things yes i i i absolutely love it
and if there is a version of a tool that
is multi-use
i'll usually almost always opt for the
multi-use one as long as it's not
inferior to the single use if it's
important
you know so as an example um
you know we do resin pores a lot and we
use heat
items a lot and the heat gun
you know i i found one that was
adjustable
adjustable temperatures uh digitally
and adjustable um you know fan
so that was like you know multi-use but
also
you know we have the blow torch which is
way too much heat so i was looking for
something in between
and i could have just gotten like a
really simple butane
lighter torch but i found this other
multi-tool that was the same size as
like a
normal butane torch but there's all
these add-ons that you could do
for soldering for cutting for um
all sorts of different things so instead
of getting
one specialized tool i got one
multi-tool
but if you need if you need a special
tool get it
but always look for an alternative that
can maybe do that and more
because sometimes there is one because
sometimes there is one
yeah and we're at the 45 minute mark
oh should we like so we had a bunch of
questions that were
related to motivation but that might be
its own
that might need to be its own thing that
might need to be its own thing yeah
because that is kind of its own let's
see are there any
um there are a few more uh tools
yeah i mean like tools and materials and
stuff is like
very um very common questions we asked
yeah
we get asked so uh uh josiah from
twitter asks with so many tools and
supplies for projects
and so many projects created what
storage organization solutions have you
found work best for you
so i'll say we're better at storing the
tools than we are the projects
that we create because sometimes they're
really big like a cat wheel
um for the tools
um our storage solutions are definitely
still in progress
but um i think one really cool thing
that we have that doesn't on camera
match are the little tiny drawers for
like
screws and nails and stuff oh yeah those
oh yeah yeah the little
it's uh the set of little tiny drawers
that we have we're gonna have to link to
a lot of stuff yeah
um that you can put labels on
that are the perfect size for like a
pack of screws or pack of nails and we
have those super organized which is very
helpful
we also have um just like the plastic
clear
sets of stackable drawers on our
shelves in the garage and i'm like such
a big
drawer person i know like adam's is adam
savage that doesn't like drawers
drawers are where things go to die but
clear drawers but clear drawers that are
labeled clear drawers that are labeled
and so i love clear drawers that are
labeled on shelves as opposed to just
shelves because i think shelves are
where things go to die
not because you can't see them but
because yourselves get so cluttered by
just like temporarily sitting stuff
there
that they become useless yeah and so
like i like shelves
i like cabinets i like boxes within
boxes within boxes
we also because because the the clear
drawers that we have also protect things
from getting dusty
if they were open then they'd get dusted
yeah which is why i also like our um
cabinets you know we've had these for
like a couple years now
and i think our cabinets would be
improved by some drawers inside the
cabinets
or like some little stacking wire
shelves i think we need that to take
more advantage of the height in some of
them
yeah but these shelves have been great
keeping things
safe from dust and being able to like um
take advantage of vertical storage and
like we love our pegboard too
yeah like the pegboard for the grab and
go stuff and we have metal pegboards
which
are awesome like they're super sturdy
and they're in tinier segments they're
in like
i don't know like a foot and a half by
two and a half foot
tall segments yeah something along those
lines
and so like they're when you're
installing them they're easy to handle
because they're smaller pieces um but
yeah i think like
peg boards are great packages are good
for the grab and go
for grab and go clear storage is great
for
um you know like we keep all of our like
safety gear and those little clear
drawers
um yeah but sometimes you also just need
metal cabinets
because stuff's heavy yeah exactly like
resin
all of our resin is or like that cabinet
or
like you know right here we do a lot of
our like heavy tools in this one right
here
that like we don't necessarily want to
hang on the pad yeah board yeah
pegboard shelves are also nice
the little shelves you can hook into
there for stuff that is you use enough
that it's grab and go but it's hard to
hang it from a hook like our little
orbital
sanders yeah but i think that like lots
of people know about cabinets
and about pegboard metal pegboard's a
big improvement but also
i think that we are big advocates of
clear
plastic storage containers we have them
inside too they're all in the closet
doing so many of them clear plastic
storage containers with labels
you need a label maker get a label maker
for your workshop yeah it's necessary
you could even get multiple colors and
you could like
color code maybe we'll do that in the
future who knows
all right one last um
one last question right there or we end
this would be a pretty short one um
common data from twitter
asks what are some materials and tools
that early on in your channel you had no
idea about but now are must-haves
i mean i don't know yeah i was gonna say
resin but like i don't know if we
i think that also you know i think that
that we've gotten a few questions about
resin but like
one thing that might tie it in is like
that we
maybe haven't said here is resin is
really good
for a few reasons one it's
always an adventure and slightly
unpredictable i know that like people
are like you've done resin so many times
shouldn't you like understand it by now
but it always flows in different ways it
always like
has some slight mystery and
unexpectedness to it even in the one
million glitter special
we did it upside down so when we peeled
it out we had no clue what it was going
to look like well
i'll i'm going to um go back to saying
that is a positive for us because we're
making videos and we want them to be
interesting
i don't think you necessarily want to be
interesting or a surprise if you're just
making your own river table
but the unpredictability of resin can
sometimes
lead to really cool things artistically
yeah because like it does kind of
it's like watercolor like it's just
gonna have its own cool patterns and
stuff
built into it by nature yeah so we love
resin
because it's like artistic you know
it adds like an artistic and colorful
element structural it's structural like
you can
and we've done this you we can just you
can just pour like a blank slab of resin
and use it for structural purposes yeah
it is
adhesive yeah it can glue things
together
i mean when you there's this website
called this to that where you like say
what what how do i want to attach blank
to blank
there's all sorts of answers all over
the place but resin is usually the
answer
for everyone and hey that's another
great um it's not
i don't think that maybe there's an app
version but on the
apps for makers it's a website for
makers this to that
how to glue stuff together if you want
to glue glass to metal
like i think one of the only answers is
resin you know
i mean you know resin works for most
things resin works for almost everything
um or epoxy you know resin epoxy what's
the difference i don't know they're
close enough
yeah this is how expert we are but i
think that's like
the main thing
you know cause like 3d printers you had
pretty early on
i would say like we have we are spoiled
with the cnc
we didn't have that initially yeah yeah
this is really nice
when you need a cnc you it's really nice
it's really nice to have a cnc
and that was something we didn't have
earlier you can do it with alternatives
but it's just
way more work that's right that's why i
categorized it as like us being spoiled
um yeah but i think resin's the biggest
thing that changed
all sorts of aspects of what we do like
even on the
um diy cat kiss cat house we originally
were thinking that we were going to do
that with just paper mache then we said
nope covered in rolls
it's structural this is kind of an
adjacent thing but air conditioning for
our workshop oh
game changer game changing absolute game
changer the first like
one and a half summers of doing our
channel we had no ac
yeah and it was just so bad yeah
you know and the winters too we had no
heat so that's
probably the biggest life changer yeah
and another than resin i don't know
another huge life changer for us is all
of the
filming and audio equipment that we've
we've gone that has really
improved our specific
process in our lives but it's not really
diy that's not really diy i feel like
i want to share my thoughts on all of
that but i'm not sure if the podcast is
the place for it needs to be visual
to a certain degree or maybe we'll do um
a like content creation
questions answering your content
creation questions yeah maybe we'll do a
podcast
we did get some questions kind of
related to that like sharing your
projects online and
behind the scenes decision making and
stuff um
but it's more content creation specific
than like diy specifically and
i'll try to make it interesting for
people who aren't going to do this too
because like
so much of what we do is so impractical
for anyone else in the world
that's why we keep having to do like
well now we make decisions this way but
before we had a channel it was this way
it's like this is
this desk that we're at right now the
only people that would need the desk
are us like like
like like content creator husband wife
teams
or like i saw a question i don't
remember if we wrote it down
but um there was a question that was
like how do you motivate yourself to do
um like impractical projects
um you know because it's very easy if
you're like well
i i need a side table
so like i'm gonna try to save money by
like making my own side table yeah you
know there's like a practical use for it
but how do you convince yourself to make
a
cat kiss cat house yeah you know what i
mean like some things are a little bit
more unknown and that's that is kind of
a hard thing to answer because we
really only well i guess there's
different different
different definitions of impractical
most of the impractical stuff we made
we have done since we started the
channel there were some
things that had a veil of practicality
but
like we just wanted we just wanted like
our big marquee love letters
who who needs big marquee letters you
don't really need them we just wanted
them so it kind of comes down to like
well do you want it yeah
even if it's impractical because if you
want it if you want it enough that's
your motivation yeah okay so that's a
tease on the motivation
enough enough motivation we're going to
save them for a whole podcast but for
now
it's time for thing of the week
so my thing of the week are stretchy
pins
sometimes a man wears stretchy pants for
fun
but uh specifically this is like a
random side tangent uh we were contacted
by our wedding photographer to help them
do uh
uh beauty and the beast themed photo
shoot once a long time ago a long time
ago
and um the pants that i wore on that
shoot
were amazing they they were
inspirational
um they uh in the pocket
there's like a hidden elastic stretchy
band
so that when you sit down and your body
shape
changes it stretches because like you
know
wearing workout pants or comfy pants or
like you know
pjs there's that stretchiness and that's
why it's comfortable
but wearing jeans or something like that
that's so inflexible
when you sit down your body gets
squished
by your your your your buy your pants
buy your pants
and it's so interesting because like
with this new style of hiding elastic
there's no stretch visible there's no
seams it's like camouflaged by the
belt loops kind of and like where your
belt would be like the piece of fabric
looks like it's the seam
well no you don't even like yeah it's
like there's a seam
where the pocket seam would usually be
but instead of it being a seam
it's an overlapping layer yeah but it
looks like a seam
it looks like a seam but that just it
just did its moves
yeah and it's it's fascinating to me
because like
like my jeans are stretchy jeans yeah
but it's different because it's like my
whole fabric is a certain level of
stretch
and i my guess is if my jeans
had that little hidden thing they would
be even more comfortable
because like there's only so much
stretch you can build into like the
waistband because there's so much more
stitching and stuff
yeah in that area my guess is that it's
like a little bit more expensive to
manufacture but like
they're not that much more expensive
than normal pants yeah you got yours on
amazon yeah yeah and like i'm like
why doesn't everyone use the hidden
pocket
straps stretchy pants full of these
yeah because i wear shorts all the time
cause like my
my legs get hot if i'm in pants yeah
anyways
it seems really random but like guys
look it up
super stretchy shorts no one will know
you're in comfy pants and you don't need
to look it up because we're going to
have a link
in the description look in the
description yeah to evan's stretchy
shorts that he discovered
now are these the best stretchy shorts
we don't know you've tried a couple
and these are like the first ones that
you're like yeah these are good yeah
yeah right right yeah yeah yeah i i
tried
well i i thought one was going to be it
but they came in and they didn't have it
so i've only tried two really yeah so
you know the the quest can continue but
like use this as a starting point
because
on your stretchy pants journey i'm your
stretchy schwartz journey
caleb what's your thing of the week the
bachelor it's kind of our thing of the
week yeah it's kind of our thing of the
week shared but
also the bachelor of the bachelorette
interchangeable
but you know i think it's a a good thing
to claim right now because a new season
just started
yeah you know and it's been an
interesting season so you know what it's
just really fun to sit there
and chuck touch touch
touch and we so i used to watch the
bachelorette
and the bachelor like with my mom back
in the day and we would watch and we
would judge and it was so fun
and i kind of fell out of the habit of
watching like around college and after
um because it's most fun when you have
someone to watch with
and judge um kayla and i pause the show
so much that's so much we keep the
remote in between us
oh and then like when there's an awkward
part i like pause and i like run around
ah that's so awkward
evan has to run away when it's too
awkward um but then like also like when
when
someone says something the wrong way
then i'm like ooh
he or she should have said it this way i
wonder if this is what they meant or are
are they really insensitive in that way
yeah or like
i'm like oh when when he or she said
that i think that was like that was it
for them that's incompatible
or like oh i can't believe why are they
being so awkward at this point like
they had good chemistry earlier and now
all of a sudden they're cooking in the
kitchen
i wonder what about that threw off their
dynamics
look at her face look at her face she is
not happy right now you could tell he
can't tell
we can tell you know so we just it's so
fun it's so fun to
like you just get to judge all these
people dating you know
and like you know it's like we don't
know these people they could be
great and you know it could all just be
in the editing it's not like we're like
live
tweeting like oh this person sucks no
we're not
we're just judging quietly to ourselves
in the comfort of our own home
it's a judgment-free judge zone
judgment-free judgment between the two
of us
yeah judgment-free and we can judge all
we want and it's just
it's fun it's fun and it's a it's a fun
thing to just
talk about it creates a lot of talking
opportunities
and we like talking and hanging out yeah
and i know that there's
a lot of people that are like oh it's
all so fake and this and that and it's
like
you know i know a lot of it is produced
but i also know that it's in the best
interest of the show
if the it works out between the couple
because their whole premise is built on
finding love and if every single couple
ended up breaking up within a few months
which sometimes they do
but if it happened every single time
then it like devalues the show so it's
in their best interest to like
actually make it work you know and so
like i
you know there is some like fake stuff
in the production and
curveballs thrown in but there's also
like realness to it too which i think
makes it interesting
yeah yeah i think it's interesting too
it's fun
yeah yeah give it a shot especially if
you have someone to watch it with
like that you're living with and you
guys can always watch it together yeah
or even if you just like facetime
somebody yeah you know and like
judge together yeah like we started we
started watching the current season
we we were watching old stuff but we
moved up to the current season
so we could like like kind of like
gossip yeah we like text my mom or we
text your sister
yeah they're like oh my gosh oh can you
believe yeah
we check to make sure they've watched it
first no spoilers
yeah yeah yeah we always make sure we're
up to date yeah yeah but it's it's fun
all right guys and that brings us to the
end of today's episode
thank you to everyone who submitted
questions on all the various platforms
um thank you guys for tuning in and
listening
and uh giving us a purpose to sit down
and just chat about stuff
share some of our our knowledge um and
uh i hope you're having a great day if
you haven't heard we are in the middle
of a prank
yes the prank is to get random people
who don't know us
to listen to our podcast and be confused
yeah because if you don't
know us from youtube stuff then this
podcast will make no sense to you no
sense no sense
why do people listen to these people if
you want to be in on the prank too and
contribute
head over to whatever platform you are
on
give us a good review it'll push us up
in the charts
i noticed the other day we were like
number seven on australia
so maybe we pranked some australians
and also it's fun reading your reviews
because some of you guys are getting
very creative with them
and we appreciate a little bit of humor
delivered to our inbox
um so uh so that's that's a prank hope
you're having a great day it's your
birthday
happy birthday and we'll see you in the
next content not all the podcast
listeners know kakwa
that's more of a stream thing well
google it
tune into our live streams all right bye